bonsoir mathieu et un merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france la relaxe 1
au titre de la liberté d'information
justice a été rendue on imagine un
soulagement
bonsoir stéphanie de murs rue oui un
soulagement évidemment et on ne peut pas
parler ce soir de liberté de la presse
au de liberté d'expression sans avoir
une pensée évidemment pour romane
protasiewicz qui a été qui a été enlevée
qui a été kidnappé la communauté
internationale condamne évidemment mais
je crois que ce n'est pas ce qu'il
passait assez fort enfin on va revenir
sur le sujet mais on ne peut pas parler
de liberté de la presse ce soir si on
n'a pas une pensée pour romane de
protester beach oui je suis soulagée
même si effectivement on s'attendait à
cette décision puisque mon confrère
gérard fumex avait été relaxée il ya de
ça un mois puisque les auditions les
convocations était en décalé toutefois
effectivement ce qu'on peut regretter
dans cette affaire c'est que on est dû
aller s'expliquer à la barre du tribunal
et qu'on a entendu des choses pas très
sympa à voir même mensongères et que
même un moment mais reproché en est
remis en cause mais ma qualité de
journaliste en nous disant en me disant
simplement monsieur justin contrats y
ait pas de carte de presse donc vous
n'êtes pas journaliste
la radio qui vous emploie est
associative donc n'importe quelle
association embauche un étudiant et puis
il devient journaliste
non je crois qu'il faut être sérieux
deux minutes j'ai un contrat travail de
journaliste pour une radio qui est
conventionnée avec le conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel il faut arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi et est resté est resté
sérieux dans cette période qui est
compliquée où on a des manifestations
qui sont interdits que c'était encore le
cas ce week end c'est alors finalement
elle a été autorisée par le tribunal des
strips de grenoble la manifestation pour
la liberté la manifestation des 100
masques 1 comme on l'appelle ici
merlane excitation en soutien au peuple
palestinien a été interdite à à paris on
a aujourd'hui dans notre pays des
éléments qui sont inquiétants quant à la
liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse concernant vos poursuite quelques
mois encore vous avec le recul est ce
que vous voulez
expliqué elle était légitime selon vous
judiciairement parlant
jusqu'à un certain point on l'avait déjà
évoqué sur votre antenne il était pour
moi
normal de devoir s'expliquer à la
gendarmerie
parce qu'effectivement on goûte on était
sur le taxiway de l'aéroport au dancing
non pas sur les pistes comme l'a
prétendu le ministère public un par
contre de devoir aller jusqu à la barre
du tribunal pour le répéter c'est
choquant est que le ministère public
essaye de passer en force avec des
arguments de sécurité en prétextant que
la sécurité civile ne pouvait pas
travailler en prétextant que le trafic
aérien a été perturbé ça par contre
c'est choquant on a dépassé les limites
moi je suis je suis pour le débat public
donc qu'on s'interroge pourquoi il y
avait deux journalistes avec treize
militants sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
d'annecy le 12 septembre 2020 ok mais au
poste de gendarmerie ça suffit pas
besoin d'aller à la barre du tribunal et
des chroniques comme ça d'être jetés
comme ça en pâture devant devant la
justice vous parliez de liberté de la
presse la france n'est plus que 34e au
classement mondial 2021 la liberté de la
presse établi par reporters sans
frontières diriez vous que les
conditions dans lesquelles vous
travaillez ont changé au fil des années
donc vous ne soyez pas très âgées
effectivement merci stéphanie de muri
c'est très gentil
elles ont changé mais ils ont changé
dans un délai qui est très récent ce
qu'on peut observer c'est que depuis
l'aller le mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
on a d'une part une défiance des
journalistes de la part de certaines
personnes et d'autre part d'effort
violentes qui sont beaucoup plus tendu
avant ça tout se passait très bien et
surtout j'ai envie de dire surtout en
province comme c'est le cas ici
après elles se sont tendues depuis les
gilets jaunes se sont tendus également
avec saison tim à ce que les gens qui
sont sceptiques mais pourquoi elles
s'étendent
elles s'étendent parce que on essaye de
moins en moins de donner la parole aux
gens en interdit des manifestations
là on va réprimer sévèrement puisque ce
matin des militants étaient condamnées
alors le parquet se prend les pieds dans
le tapis
dans cette histoire c'est le premier
militant a été condamné à 200 euros
d'amendé
avec sursis les six suivants ont reçu
une réquisition pour 200 euros damende
ferme mais ont reçu l'appel avant
d'avoir la condamnation
et puis ce matin trois nouveaux ont
comparu et e.on ont été condamnés à 3
100 à 200 euros d'amendé ferme
donc on ne sait plus sait plus où donner
de la tête on ne comprend pas le
comportement de la justice vis-à-vis des
militants d'extinction rébellion et des
amis de la terre
c'est ça qui stresse les gens les gens
peuvent plus s'exprimer sans être pointé
du doigt un en fait le débat public
souffre d'un syndrome qui vient à mon
sens des réseaux sociaux c'est à dire
qu' on ne peut pas avoir de débat public
n'y a pas de mise à mort à la fin il
faut forcément qu on est inquiet tort et
qu'on ne l'entende plus à la fin non on
peut opposer deux points de vue et les
opposer avec avec richesse avec
franchise sans que ça se termine par des
arrestations ou un lâchage sur les
réseaux sociaux de d'une ou deux ou de
l'autre partie dernière question le
projet de loi sécurité globale avec son
fameux article 24 1 finalement censuré
il a fait couler beaucoup d'encre à cet
article par le conseil constitutionnel
censure est en tout cas ce n'est que
justice
selon vous ce n'est que justice
non moi je regrette qu'il faille aller
jusqu'au dernier rempart de cette
démocratie c'est république pour pour
qu'on censure vraiment ce qu'il y a
censuré parce qu'il reste quand même des
choses dans le texte qui sont qu'ils
sont inquiétants que l'article 24 fin
l'ancien article 24 parce qu'il a pu
tenir là c'est pas tout le texte
effectivement c'est une dérive il a été
censuré ouf parce que c'était vraiment
la chose la plus inquiétante dans dans
ce texte mais il reste d'autres choses
et je crois que nous parlementaires aura
dit s'inquiéter bien avant et faire le
boulot
bien avant ça c'est très inquiétant et
puis on ne parle plus du tout du rapport
de jean marie delarue des journalistes
des forces de l'ordre ont travaillé
pendant des semaines à beauvau pour elle
à bourg et une liste de propositions qui
était très intéressante et ce travail
pour le moment n'est utilisé par
personne et ça a également c'est un
élément qui est regrettable donc oui en
ce moment on va jusqu'au au bout des
parachutes que la démocratie française
peut utiliser pour éviter de tomber
réellement dans dans la dérive mais on y
est tombé à quelque part ce week end
on est dans un pays où le ministre de
l'intérieur a porté plainte contre une
opposante politique qui avait porté un
jugement de valeur sur une manifestation
des forces de l'ordre mais sans porter
injures ont plus est une ancienne
journaliste dont elle connaît très bien
les règles et malgré tout le se retrouva
qu avec une plainte donc un quelqu'un va
être le parachute cette fois ci pour
rappeler le ministre de l'intérieur à la
raison moi je me pose la question
j'attends de voir ce qui va se passer
merci beaucoup mais tu éteins de h2o
d'avoir été sur rt front sol